So as we talked about
in our last video,
the new Google Sign-In
Library contains
a number of improvements
over what we had before.
It's smaller, it's a
better user experience,
and it accepts all Google
accounts even if they're not
Google+ accounts.
But how exactly do you
add it to an iOS project?
Well, let's find out in this
exciting episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I have a fresh
new Xcode app that I
want to add the new
Google Sign-In Library to.
For the purpose
of this video, I'm
going to do everything
in Swift 1.2,
but it's very similar
in Objective-C,
just add a few more
brackets here and there.
Now, the first thing
I'm going to go through
is going through all of the
configuration and setup steps,
always the most fun
part of any project.
That was sarcasm.
Actually, it's not too bad now
with the new configuration flow
that we have.
So the first thing I'll do
is go to developers.googl
e.com/mobile/add.
Now I'll need to
enter my project name
and my bundle ID here.
And on this next page, I'm going
to select Sign-In and click
the Enable button.
It's going to go ahead
and create an OAuth client
ID for me behind the scenes,
which is very helpful.
And I don't need to do
anything else right now,
so I'm just going
to click Continue.
And then on this last
page, I have a plist file
that I am going to download.
I also have this
important line of text
that I'm going to need
for my podspec file,
so let's copy that.
OK, up next, I'm going
to configure my CocoaPod
to install the Google
Sign-In Library.
I'll assume you know a little
something about CocoaPods,
but if not, why not
check out this video?
So I'll do a little pod
init here, edit the file,
and paste in that
line I copied earlier
from our Configuration Tool.
You'll notice this is the
Google/signin CocoaPod, which
not only includes Google
Sign-In, but also a few helper
libraries that will help me
with the configuration process.
So I'm going to
type pod install,
and CocoaPods will download the
Google Sign-In Library for me.
And once that's done, I'll
open up my .xcworkspace to see
my new project.
Oh, hello, pod library.
Glad you could join us!
Now remember that plist
file I downloaded earlier?
I'm just going to add it to
my Xcode project like so.
OK, now, next step, we
need to add two URL schemes
to our project.
These basically allow
other Google apps
to properly send information
back to our application
when the user is
done signing in.
Now to add a URL
scheme, we're going
to select our app
target here, go to Info,
and scroll down to the bottom
where it says URL Schemes,
and then click this plus
button to add a new one.
The first URL scheme we're
going to add is our bundle ID.
You can just add it here
in the URL scheme field
and leave everything else as is.
OK, so that one was
pretty straightforward.
But the next one we need to
add is our OAuth 2.0 client
ID in reverse.
I know, weird, right?
Now, in case you don't
have that memorized,
you can actually find it
here in the plist file
that we just added
to our project.
See?
There it is.
We'll just copy that
and paste it here
in the URL Scheme field.
OK, finally, get to
write a line of code.
Hurray!
Now, before I get there, since
I am doing this in Swift,
I need to add a
bridging header file.
So I'm going to use the trick
of creating a dummy Objective-C
file, telling Xcode, yes,
I would like you to create
a bridging header file for me,
and then deleting these two
files.
Now, in my bridging header,
I'm just going to import
Google/SignIn.h.
Now I can go into
my AppDelegate,
and in my application
didFinishLaunching method,
I'm going to make a
call to GGLContext.share
dInstance().configureWithError.
This method will look and see
what Google/CocoaPod libraries
I have added in our project.
If it finds any, it will
attempt to configure them
by reading in constants from
that plist file that I added.
In fact, if I run
my app right now,
you'll see here in the
console that it successfully
configured SignIn.
It'll also report
that it didn't bother
trying to configure things
like Analytics or Admob,
because we haven't installed
those CocoaPods yet.
But if we had, it would try and
set those libraries up as well.
Whew, that was an awful lot
of setup, but we're done.
Let's get into writing
some more code.
There are two delegates you
need to be aware of when
you're dealing with Sign-in.
The GIDSignInDelegate
is the Delegate
that will be called when the
user has finished signing in.
Good candidates for this
are your AppDelegate,
your main ViewController,
or perhaps
a singleton class that
represents your user.
The GIDSignInUIDelegate
is the delegate
that our library requires
in order to properly display
the embedded WebView.
It's a little weird in that it's
required for you to set this,
but it contains all
optional methods
that you generally don't need
to write if your SignInDelegate
ends up being a ViewController.
So very frequently,
you're just going
to say that the
UIViewController that
contains your sign-in button
is your SignInUIDelegate,
and then not implement any
of the optional methods.
That's what I
typically do, anyway.
This'll make more sense when
you see it in action, trust me.
So let's start with
our GIDSignInDelegate.
I think maybe I'll declare
that my AppDelegate is
my SignInDelegate.
So I'll add the
declaration here,
and I can set it to self
here in my application
didFinishLaunching method.
And now I'll need to
implement the required
signIn didSignInForUser
withError method.
For now, I'm just going to print
a few pieces of information
if we succeed and print out
the error message if we fail.
Note that I'm
still on Swift 1.2,
so I'm using println
instead of print.
Oh, and by the way, note that
also getting an error here
is pretty common.
The most frequent cause is that
the user clicks Cancel instead
of signing in, so don't
throw an assertion error
here or anything.
Handle it gracefully.
Oh, and while we're
here at the AppDelegate,
I'll also need to handle
any incoming URLs.
Remember, the way
Google's native apps
send information back
to our application
is through an incoming URL.
That's why I had to
set those crazy URL
schemes back to the
beginning, as you recall.
So we need to make sure we
capture these incoming URLs.
And the way to do that
is to add a application
openURL sourceApplication
annotation method
and pass in all the
information along
to the corresponding Google
SignIn handleURL method,
kind of like so.
OK, next up, let's go add
that GIDSignInUIDelegate
that I was talking about.
I'm going to go into
our ViewController
here, because that's where the
sign-in button is eventually
going to live.
I'm going to declare that
it's our GIDSignInUIDelegate,
and then I will set that down
here in our viewDidLoad method.
And then we'll never
speak of it again.
Really, that's all
I need to do here.
All that's left to do now is
actually sign the user in.
Now for that, I'm
going to use a button.
Adding a sign-in
button using Google's
built-in sign-in button class
is pretty straightforward.
I'll just need to add a
view to my storyboard here.
We'll make it roughly
button shaped,
and maybe we can add some
constraints to align it
properly.
Then I'm going to declare
that our View's Custom
Class is a GIDSignInButton,
and we're done.
No, really, that's it.
Because this View is
now a sign-in button,
it knows to start the
Google sign-in process
when the user clicks on it.
Heck, let's run this right
now in the simulator and see.
So you can see that my
mysterious gray rectangle
is now a beautiful
blue sign-in button.
And when I click it, Google
starts the sign-in process.
You'll also see that I get
the embedded ViewController
because there are no
native Google apps
to swap to in the simulator.
And when I'm done, you'll get a
printout here of those messages
that I put in my
didSignInForUserDelegate
method.
Now obviously, it'd be
silly to make our user
sign in every time they
start our app, which
is what our app currently does.
Most likely in the
real world, you're
going to want to cache some of
your user's profile information
locally so that
when they return,
you remember who
they are right away.
However, we're
still going to want
to sign them in using
Google services as well.
Partly this will ensure that
if, say, our user updates
their profile picture or
something on Google's side,
that will get retrieved
and reflected in our app.
But also, if we're using
Google Sign-In in order
to perform other actions
using Google services--
and I'll talk about that
more in the next video--
we'll be sure to have an
up-to-date access token.
To help with this, Google also
has a signInSilently method.
This method will
try to sign the user
in without showing them any
kind of confirmation dialog.
So when we start up our app,
we're going to want to call it.
If it works, then our
user is signed in,
and we can update
any info as needed.
And if it doesn't, well, then
we can show our Sign In button.
Now, note that this
signInSilently method will only
succeed if our user has
signed in to the app
previously on this
device, hasn't signed out
in the meantime,
and we haven't asked
for any additional
permissions or scopes.
So let's go ahead and add this.
So In my ViewController's
viewDidLoad method,
I'm just going to make a
call to signInSilently.
And now when I start my
app, I'll wait a moment,
and I'm once again signed in.
Now that we can
sign the user in,
we're going to want to sign
them out, at the very least
for testing purposes.
So I'm going to add
a simple button here.
Now, I'm just going to create
an action to go with it.
And in there, I will
call GIDSignIn.shared
Instance.signOut.
Note that no Delegate methods
are called here or anything.
It's all done locally
and nearly instantly.
And now I can sign out and
sign in as much as I'd like.
Finally, it'd be awfully nice
if our interface actually
changed when the user signs in.
For that, I'm going to
need my AppDelegate, which,
as you recall, is
my SignInDelegate,
to talk to my
ViewController here.
Obviously there's a lot
of ways we could do that.
We could create our own
protocol and delegate.
We could send up
an NSNotification,
but I think I'll
do it by setting
a property in my
AppDelegate that
is a method to call when my
user has finished signing in.
And then I can have
my ViewController
pass an appropriate method to
my AppDelegate as that property.
I'm not going to go over
all the plumbing here.
You've probably done
something like this before.
But when all is
said and done, I'm
going to have my AppDelegate
tell my ViewController to call
this refreshInterface method.
Now, this method will see if
there is a valid currentUser
object on my
GIDSignInSharedInstance,
and if so, I can populate a few
on-screen labels and images.
Put that together with
a few more UI elements,
and you might have something
that looks a little like this.
Ah, nice.
So there you go.
That's how you can get
started adding Google Sign-In
to your own iOS project.
For more details, please
be sure to check out
all the documentation here.
But we're not done yet.
For a few more interesting
topics on Sign-In,
follow me to the next video.
Come on!
What?
What are you still doing here?
I'm waiting for you
in the next video.
Go on.
Click it.
Right there.
Come on!
We got to go.
There's learning
to be had, people!
[MUSIC PLAYING]